kids eat free do we have your attention
now in today's eight on your side we
take a look at eight places rolling out
some serious summer savings where kids
can eat free
summer is here but kids may be the only
ones jumping for joy for this season as
parents are reeling over Financial
stresses savings expert treybaj says
don't go overboard with going out as we
know it's so expensive right now so
maybe it's like once or twice a month
and it feels really special so setting
some boundaries around going out can be
really helpful Jersey Mike's offers a
free kids meal with the purchase of an
adult one every Sunday California Pizza
Kitchen celebrating the start of summer
with the kids eat free meal from Monday
to Thursday until July 31st with the
purchase of an entree Chick-fil-A
offering kids eat free from 5 to 7 30
p.m at select locations on Tuesdays and
every Tuesday and Thursday from 4 to 10
p.m Denny's offers kids 12 and under to
eat free AARP has 15 off at Denny's and
so that's a great value if you're
bringing the whole family and going out
for a fun casual lunch here are a few
more kids eat free Tuesday deals at
Famous Dave's kids can eat free all day
Tuesday with the purchase of an adult
meal Marie Callender is offering the
same on Tuesdays and Saturdays Ruby's
Diner offers kids 12 and under eat free
from 4 pm until closing Ruby Tuesday
kids eat free from 4 to 10 p.m with the
purchase of an adult meal and it
cherries between 10 a.m and 11 P.M every
Tuesday you can get one free kids meal
per order
and you're going to want to download the
crazy coupon lady app to find the latest
savings and Deals on everything kids and
keep in mind that most kids eat free
promos they don't let you stack the deal
stack the deal no you can't so you can't
be using any other coupons or deals at
the same
okay